Summit we signed a new illegal
immigration deal to protect our borders
over the weekend we facilitated a sale
of Silicon Valley Bank at no cost to the
taxpayer
we have launched this
in partnership with Australia in the US
launched our integrated review and
boosted our defense budget Mr Speaker
this morning I had meetings the
ministerial colleagues and others in
addition to my duties in this house I
shall have further such meetings later
today Jessica litz thank you Mr Speaker
I've worked for years with women brought
here illegally as sex slaves raped by 30
men a day last week the Prime Minister
tweeted that these victims would be
denied access to support from our modern
slavery system a tweet that traffickers
will hold up to these women and say see
no one will help you before the Prime
Minister parrots his prepared answer
about increases in the number of people
accessing our modern slavery system lets
me educate him and everyone else in this
house that the biggest increase in the
last 10 years has been from the huge
increase in British adults and children
trafficked for sex and crime within
Britain not a number but they should be
proud of how exactly will I help the
next woman I meet brought here illegally
from being repeatedly raped if she as he
tweeted is denied access from our
mother's life
Mrs Mr Speaker just to correct The
Honorable lady it is actually now a
minority of people in our modern slavery
referral system that are from the UK
that was not the intention of the
legislation when it was introduced we
have a proud record of supporting
victims of modern slavery
and thousands of victims are supported
every year here in the UK and that will
not change as we grip illegal
immigration
[Applause]
Mr Speaker on Monday the Home Secretary
said that in recent decades there has
been the immigration to this country has
been too high and all the benches
opposite held their disapproval they
want higher immigration not lower
cheat for labor we need to invest in the
skills of our own young people
yeah
well Mr speaker model A friend is right
that we do need to encourage long-term
investment in the domestic Workforce and
we'll hear more from this in the
chancellor later this afternoon that the
department for work and pensions is
directing support at sectors with labor
shortages like construction and social
care and our new skills boot camps are
part of a dramatic rebooting of our
skill system to support workers to get
the skills that they need the welcome to
lead in the opposition kill Starbuck
uh thank you Mr Speaker Last Summer the
Prime Minister claimed he wanted to
protect free speech and put a stop to no
platforming so how concerned was he by
last week's campaign by Tory MPS to
cancel a broadcaster
prime minister
Mr
Mr Speaker as I said as I said at the
time the issues between Gary lineker and
the BBC were for them to resolve and I'm
very glad I'm very I'm very glad that
they did and we're looking forward to
watching match the day again on our
screensaver
Mr Mr Speaker the sight of them howling
with rage over a tweet signing Greening
letters in their dozens desperately
trying to cancel a football highlight
show that should have been laughable
instead it led to a farcical weekend
with the national broadcast being
accused of dancing to the government's
tune by its own employees rather than
blame everyone else why doesn't it take
some responsibility stand up to his
snowflake MPS wage in war on Free Speech
[Applause]
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker just the usual
usual political opportunism
the labor party because I don't I don't
know if he noticed I don't know if he
knows this but actually first the shadow
attorney general and then the shadow
Home Secretary actually criticized the
language that had been used
[Applause]
surprise
surprise he's
he's a chance to jump on a political
bandwagon and changed his mind First
Armor so Mr Speaker
tonight
I'm not being funny I think I'm a
constituent to get to the budget the
more that you showed the more you
progressed question so please my
constituents interested if yours aren't
Mr Speaker they want more of a
plan understand you could just
that we're in a real problem does he
accept that people's concerns about the
BBC have been made worse because the
government chose to put a Tory donor
with no broadcasting experience in
charge of the BBC
[Applause]
as he well knows the BBC chairman was
appointed before I became
[Applause]
he was appointed he was he was appointed
and the same applies to this side this
budget matters to the people of this
country they won't hear it don't keep
questions going long the Navy prime
minister
Mr Speaker there was a rigorous in
independent and long-established process
supported by expert panel members as
well as the cross as well as the cross
party dcms select committee now that is
right that process that process is being
that process is being independently
reviewed by the office for commissioner
of public appointments and we should
allow that review to conclude
the problem is the chair of the BBC
isn't just any old Tory donor
so close to the Prime Minister audit Mr
I want you to be
No Ordinary Tori don't he's so close to
prime minister he's been described as
his mentor he helped arrange an 800 000
pound credit line for the former prime
minister a minor detail he forgot to
tell the select committee which
scrutinized his appointment does the
Prime Minister think that his friend's
position is still tenable
Mr Speaker as I've just said
the offers for in the independent office
for commissioner of public appointment
is reviewing what was a rigorous
independent process to appoint the
chairman instead of pre-judging and
preempting that review we should let it
conclude and wait for the outcome that
is the right way to do things and that's
what the government will do
Mr Speaker when people with links to the
Tory party somehow find themselves in
senior positions at the BBC it's
important that their impartiality is
seen to be Beyond reproach so has the
promise to received assurances but no
one with links to the Tory party was
lobbied by Tory MPS or involved in the
decision that saw match of the day
effectively canceled
Mr Speaker these as I said these These
are matters these are matters for the
BBC to resolve and it's right it's right
that the BBC as an important institution
takes its obligations to impartiality
seriously right but I I care about the
integrity and partiality of Institutions
the BBC but also the Civil Service Mr
Speaker and it's right that those
processes carry on properly but what I
would say to him what I would say to him
on this matter there is an independent
review it's right that that process
concludes and he would I would hope
respect that process
[Applause]
he comes here today with his Minnie
Mouse platitudes pretending the actions
of his party have nothing to do with him
but the whole country saw how he kept
quiet and hid behind the playground
bullies while they tried to drive
someone out Simply for disagreeing with
them
partial public broadcaster free of
government interference is a crucial
pillar in our country but isn't that put
at risk by the council culture addicts
on his benches the BBC leadership that
caves into their demands and a prime
minister too weak to do anything about
them
Mr Speaker we're not going to take any
lectures on cancel culture from the
party officer
you know but we know what we know all
this is about he's avoided it in six
questions the actual the substance of
the issue that this underlied this tweet
and that's what has he done in this past
week the only thing he and his party
have done is voted against our bill to
stop the votes Mr Speaker
siding with people Smugglers over the
British people that's the
that's happened instead what have we
done is include a new migration deal
with France Mr Speaker we've managed to
sign a new defense partnership with our
allies the US and Australia we've
protected British startups and
defense spending and that Mr Speaker is
what delivering for Britain looks like
can I just say to you the biggest day in
the house and you want to carry on
cheering I'll tell you what my kids no
I'll be quite
because there is plenty of rumors I've
mentioned in the two-room for all sides
so let me say Angela Richardson's once
again on with the questions Angela
thank you Mr Speaker for decades Surrey
Research Park in Guildford has been home
to our pioneering space sector with
Surrey satellite technology limited and
now Surrey Space Center spacecraft
project which recently received 300 000
pounds to train and recruit dedicated
space engineers and create facilities to
trial space related technology will my
right honorable friend join with me in
welcoming this investment and when his
diary allows will he come and visit
Guildford to celebrate successful local
Innovation and job creation
I am I can reassure my honorable friend
that we are continuing to invest in the
UK's thriving space sector including in
her constituency a new six and a half
million pound scheme to support high
impact uh projects space South Central
as she knows is already the leading
Regional space cluster in the UK there's
more investment coming and I look
forward to either visiting myself or the
minister of State for science Innovation
and Technology to make sure that her
companies get the recognition they
deserve SMP leader Stephen Flint
Mr Speaker on Monday as households in
Scotland were Awakening to freezing
temperatures they were met with the news
that the electricity grid had been
upgraded in order to meet the Power
demands of the prime minister's new
swimming pool so may I ask him was it
whilst he was taking a leisurely dip
that he decided to leave households
Downing in their energy bills
prime minister Mr Speaker thanks to the
actions of this government what we've
provided is over 1
300 pounds to help families with their
energy bills over the last year and I
wouldn't want to preempt what the
chancellor is going to say later but
this is a government that is committed
to continuing to help people with the
cost of living and that's what you'll
hear later on Stephen Flynn you've got
to wonder what planet he's on Mr Speaker
because for households in Scotland
Energy prices haven't been frozen at two
and a half Grand and did the average
bill in Scotland has been closer to 3
500 pounds and you're tripling in just
under two years but worse than that the
chancellor is about to get to his feet
and announced at the 400 pound energy
rebate is about to be Scott for everyone
not just in Scotland but right across
these aisles so is it not the case
notorious aren't freezing energy bills
they're looking to freeze households
have been our priority which is why over
a thousand pounds of support which is
benefiting households in every part of
our country but he talks about delivery
it's now clear that we know because of
the SMP that the trains don't run on
time the police the police the police
are the police are at Breaking Point
the police are at breaking point and the
NHS in Scotland experience the longest
ever waiting list Mr Speaker that isn't
that isn't even my assessment that's
what we learned in the smp's leadership
debate last week
so thank you Mr Speaker independent
retailers of the lifeblood of our high
streets and critical to the Regeneration
of our town centers so we should cherish
and celebrate the entrepreneurs who set
them up and run them with that in mind
with the Prime Minister join me in
congratulating the winners of my recent
competition to find newcastle's Best
Loved independent shops and Market
stores namely Tony Price quality
butchers me Julie's cheeky cheesecakes
and the overall winner and that's my
Greek Bakery who only opened in January
2021 and are already expanding to a
second site
[Applause]
well I agree with my honorable friend
about the incredible benefit that small
businesses and independent retailers
bring to our high streets and our
economy I congratulate the team at an
asthma Greek Bakery for winning the
competition and I know that they will
feel reassured by their government's
investment in his constituency through
the towns deal that they have and of
course funding from the future High
streets fund Stephen Curry thank you
very much Mr Speaker just ahead of some
Patrick's Day can I thank the Prime
Minister for his recent deep engagement
with Northern Ireland and particularly
the conclusion of the Windsor framework
and hopefully we will see the executive
restored uh shortly however that
executive is facing a spiral of of
budget cuts which will stop it from
transforming Public Services on a vested
safe basis and investing in a Prosperity
agenda so will the Prime Minister and a
data Chancellor work with the Northern
Ireland parties on a financial package
in order to transform Northern Ireland
accepting data for strict conditions and
a real focus on key areas such as health
education skills and infrastructure
stuff well can I Thank The Honorable
gentleman and his his colleagues and his
party for the engagement they had uh in
the run-up to the Windsor framework it
was helpful and I appreciated his
constructive involvement and my right
honorable friend the Northern Ireland
secretary has been working closely and
will work closely with all Northern
Irish parties leading discussions on a
wide range of issues including the
public finances because I believe what
the normal gentleman believes is the
people of Northern Ireland need and
deserve effective accountable devolved
government up and running as quickly as
possible and I hope that those talks can
be constructive in leaving their aim Bob
Blackman
thank you Mr Speaker in 2016 the current
mayor of London promised zero strikes on
London Underground so today is the 135th
day of strikes since then
will my right little friend join with me
in condemning both strikes that have
brought misery to the traveling public
in London and also can condemned the
mayor of London for his failure to
address this
yeah Mr Speaker my uh mindful friend is
absolutely right uh about the misery
being inflicted on londoners uh by the
incompetent running of tfl it's worth
bearing in mind not only to the party
opposite vote against our minimum
service levels which will provide
respite for the hard-working British
public that the the mayor of London
since the pandemic has received six
billion pounds of additional funding for
transport services so for us to be in
the situation that we are find ourselves
in today is simply unacceptable
thank you Mr Speaker an investigation
reported in the guardian and the BBC
revealed that in the last year on more
than 450 instances sewage was leaking
into cancer Wards maternity units and a
e departments without urgent action the
legacy of this conservative government
on the NHS will be an image of a nurse
cleaning up sewage around a patient in a
crumbling hospital will the Prime
Minister commit to that pledge of
building 40 hospitals by 2030 including
in West Hertfordshire and will he
establish a fund to repair those
hospitals that are in a dire state of
disrepair
Mr Speaker we are investing record sums
in NHS Capital to upgrade dozens of
hospitals across the country but in
particular to build 40 new hospitals and
we are committed in particular to a new
hospital scheme at West Hertfordshire
Hospital NHS trust as part of that
program and the program is working
closely with the Trust on their plans in
lines with the approach that we have
taken nationally I'll put shop speaker
does the Prime Minister agree with me
that agritech is a vital part of the UK
economy and in particular the excellent
work of the crop and environment
Research Center at Harper Adams
University in Shropshire I know he has a
busy schedule but could he dispatch the
Secretary of State to come and look at
that research center and in particular
this the women leading science and maths
at Harper Adams and indeed leading the
world
well Mr Speaker I agree with my
honorable friend in particular Harper
Adams is a fantastic example of the type
of innovation and skills provision that
we need in our agritech sector and
that's why I'm pleased post brexit that
we can introduce the gene editing Bill
Mr Speaker which will help Drive
productivity and efficiency in our
agricultural sector even further but
the government promised the 14 new
hospitals three years ago and the prime
minister's just expressed his intention
to proceed again two years ago in Saint
Mary's Paddington Hospital serving my
constituency award ceiling fell in
during floods the Eye Hospital was
closed by a fire and the birth center of
Eternity Wars are threatened by
structural problems this week trust
managers said the infrastructure is
having an increasing impact on staff and
patients we just can't afford to
continue to waste money on failing
buildings but the hospital is waiting
for the commitment from the government
for the funding under the new hospitals
program will today be the day that the
Prime Minister commits to that
specifically yeah
Mr Speaker as I said in my previous
answer the government is committed to
the new hospitals program we've
committed record sums to NHS Capital not
just for that program but for smaller
scale upgrades across the country and
those conversations with her trust and
others are happening in the same way
across the country and I look forward to
those conversations continuing
yeah Mr Speaker governments at all level
national and local should always strive
to to deliver value for money
particularly in a cost of living crisis
therefore does the Prime Minister share
my astonishment that my local Labor led
Westminster Council voted last week to
raise council tax by two percent housing
tenants Council tenants went by seven
percent and increased allowances for its
senior councilors by up to a staggering
40.
[Applause]
please answer
Mr Speaker it is disappointing to see
that I think it's been just under a year
that the now labor run Westminster
Council has put its own counselors pay
ahead of everything else
I can't quite believe the figures that
we heard from honorable friend a
staggering an eye-watering 45 pay
increase when people across our country
and indeed the water suffering cost of
living pressures it's clear Mr Speaker
that it's only conservative run councils
that deliver for their residents
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker every
child in the UK is entitled to pre-nhs
dental treatment but with 80 percent of
practices not accepting children as new
patients is the prime minister proud of
his record on our children's dental
health
Mr Speaker we're investing three billion
pounds in NHS Gentry and because of the
reforms to the contract there will be
about 10 more activity this year above
contractor levels there are 500 more
dentists in the NHS today but also I
think almost a 45 increase in the amount
of dental care being provided to
Children Eric Thomas Mr Speaker five
years ago 40 million pounds of public
funds were set aside for brain tumor
research but recent government figures
suggest that a little less quarter of
that money has been deployed to
researchers the mechanism to distribute
research funding effectively is broken
as a result the brain tumor Community
has not seen the breakthroughs in
treatment and survival rates that many
of us believe they should have does my
primary does my friend the Prime
Minister agree with me that a unique
complex disease needs a unique response
and then what is brain tumor awareness
month will he make brain cancer a
critical research priority across all
cancers
or can I uh can I thank wonderful friend
for his thoughtful and Powerful question
he's absolutely right about the
importance of medical research being
expedited so we can deliver better care
for the people who are affected I'll
make sure that he gets a meeting with
the relevant minister so we can ensure
that that funding gets out to the people
who need it and we can bring relief to
them as quickly as we can Joanna yeah
thank you thank you Mr Speaker with the
encouragement of the British government
female prosecutors and female judges in
Afghanistan stood up for the rule of law
and for a more inclusive and equal
Nation those Left Behind are in Mortal
danger last year I met with senior
officials at the foreign office who were
open to making a specific case for at
least some of these women to be
relocated to the United Kingdom but
nothing has happened since then this
dire situation requires a prime
ministerial intervention so I'm not
asking to meet the prime minister's
officials or his ministers I'm asking
him directly will he meet with me to see
what we can do for these women yeah
finished I'm very happy to meet with the
honorable lady and she will know that we
take our obligations to those who helped
and served in Afghanistan extremely
seriously both through the Arab scheme
and the acrs scheme we have already
brought 20 000 refugees from Afghanistan
to the UK we've worked closely with the
unhcr and others on those legal routes
but I'd be happy to meet with her to
ensure that we're targeting our
compassion our generosity on the people
who most need it and not those who are
coming here illegally Caroline
speaker
for pandemics
sword with their lives
Lara my very brave young constituent is
now battling cancer and will not sit the
GCSE exams she has worked so hard for
and could be left with only a
certificate of recognition
in exceptional circumstances such as
these why can't the same principle apply
would my right honorable friend the
Prime Minister look compassionately at
this situation
prime minister start by sending my best
wishes to Lara and thanking my honorable
friend for raising her case uh in in
Parliament of course it's incredibly
upsetting and challenging for children
and young people to be diagnosed with a
serious illness and especially so close
to their exams now there are um
allowances that are made and in the
first instance students will speak to
their school or their college to make
those reasonable adjustments but I'll be
happy to make sure that we work with
vulnerable friend to find a resolution
in Lara's case
Mr Speaker I welcome the PM's numeracy
drive but did he know that some 7.1
million adults in England a functionally
illiterate is often diagnosed late in
life like with TVs J blades if at all so
would he thank the entirely voluntary
read easy who are turning this round at
just 250 pounds cost per new reader and
commit to a national strategy for
eradicating this problem that's costing
our economy 25 billion a year in Lost
competitiveness
well Mr Speaker I agree with honorable
lady literacy and numerity are critical
for adults to be able to participate
both in society and the economy I'm
happy to appraise read easy for the work
that they do look forward to learning
more about them but the best way to
solve this problem is to ensure that our
young children get the the reading
skills and training and education that
they need and I'm so pleased that
because of the reforms introduced by
this preview or previous conservative
governments particularly with phonics we
have now marched up the international
league table and have some of the best
results for reading that we've seen in a
very long time it's a fuller thank you
Mr Speaker more than a quarter of the
economic output of this country is in
sectors overseen by some of our major
Regulators such as off-ward and off gem
but historically there's been very
little in the way of oversight to say
whether doing a good job or a bad job
whether achieving International best
practice or not so can the Prime
Minister look to see what he can do to
address his historical oversight and
enable Regulators to play their part in
ensuring economic growth
Mr Speaker as always my honorable friend
makes a a very thoughtful point and he's
absolutely right about the importance of
our Regulators in driving growth
competitive investment in our economy I
know the chance will have something to
say on this later on but he should rest
assured that we will keep at it to make
sure that there is accountability and
oversight of our Regulators we all want
to see more growth in our economy and
they need to play their part in
delivering it red Stringer
Mr Speaker 20 years after defeat in the
second world war the first Japanese
bullet train traveled to 300 miles from
Tokyo to Osaka at 200 miles an hour
isn't it a measure if the government's
incompetent yes lack of commitment to
the regions uh lack of commitment to
infrastructure that it is now expected
that 24 years after a conservative
transport secretary announced that hs2
would happen that Birmingham Manchester
and London will not be linked by that
time yeah
Mr Mr Mr Speaker we're actually
delivering the biggest rail investment
this is it the the biggest the biggest
rail investment the biggest rail
investment since the Victorian era I'll
just gently point out to The Honorable
gentleman compared to when labor were
lost in office the investment the
investment going into the north is 30
higher every single year under this
conservative government we are
delivering for communities across the
north with more trains more buses more
stations and more roads because the
conservative government doesn't just
talk about it it gets on and delivers it
speaker I hope very much that later
today we'll hear news of help for
motorists and small businesses but for
most us four businesses in Bromley and
the rest of outer London they're going
to be hard hit later this year by the
mayor of London's Stills tax in a form
of an optional emission charge
money and jobs isn't it time to revisit
the Local Government Act and revise it
so that such charges can only be imposed
on London boroughs with the consent of
the boroughs themselves
well Mr Mr Speaker my honorable friend
makes an excellent point and is right
that the uh the mayor of London should
listen to the voices of commuters of
families and of small businesses as he
inflicts his damaging tax on them this
government will always be on the side of
those people and this budget will
deliver for them too a complete prime
minister's questions